[Música]
las mujeres no se matan y no se violan
merecemos vivir sin miedo a ser
agredidas y conmemoramos el día
internacional contra la violencia hacia
las mujeres para hablar de esta profunda
necesidad de cambio las invitadas a
tomar la palabra en ellas hoy son las
tesis de chile civil a sotomayor
dafne valdés paula cometa y leaf cáceres
crearon un colectivo que traduce tesis
feministas y las aplica con mensajes
contundentes poco más de un año pasó
desde su primera aparición en valparaíso
en pleno levantamiento social chileno su
himno un violador en tu camino inundó el
planeta y con millones de mujeres que
hoy replican que ninguna en el mundo
puede declararse libre de las formas de
violencia desde la bienvenida a las
tesis y comienzo preguntando un violador
en tu camino es un performance histórico
pero no es el único que han trabajado
ustedes son artistas y feministas con
estos elementos hicieron por ejemplo el
performance hundimos el miedo
cosas la verdad es que en este contexto
de crisis sanitaria esté considerando
que nuestra forma de manifestarnos la
trinchera que hemos elegido delante
específicamente la performance se vuelve
un poco complejo cierto pues realizar
performance digamos en el mismo espacio
físico por lo que durante todos estos
meses desde marzo en adelante estuvimos
trabajando en ampliar nuestro formato
hacia el vídeo performance colaborativo
también y estuvimos realizando diversos
trabajos en juana distintas temáticas
que nos parecían muy importantes de
seguir tratando y además aprovechando la
visibilidad que tiene nuestro trabajo
evidentemente o sea de alguna manera
poniendo al servicio esta plataforma
este espacio de anunciación que nosotros
tenemos a las demandas feministas
entonces trabajamos en torno a la
violencia doméstica trabajamos en torno
a la lucha por la despenalización legal
y social del aborto y luego cuando ya
se flexibilizaron un poco la
reglas las normas en torno al
confinamiento coming
salimos a la calle y realizamos esta
performance ya en el espacio público
nuevamente de hoy hundimos el miedo a
portas del plebiscito que hubo en
nuestro país el 25 pasado
para alguna manera de generar un acto
simbólico de deshacernos de todo aquello
de toda la herencia de colonial también
si por un lado de esta constitución
hecha la dictadura cívico-militar que
esperamos que ahora los fin gracias al
resultante plebiscito se cambie y deje
de oprimidos por la vía legal pero
también de todo lo más amplio excepto
del patriarcado de las gerencias
coloniales de esas presiones del
constante extractivismo castilla de hoy
vivimos en nuestros territorios entonces
de ahí que decidiéramos hacer este acto
simbólico de por donde se vino a través
del mar se fuera todo esto
herencia opresora y violenta
preguntarles cómo nació en ustedes esta
conciencia feminista que tanto se
dedican a enseñar
como nación bueno el colectivo se
constituye el año 2018 pero en verdad
nosotros hace mucho tiempo que teníamos
esta preocupación alta urgencia por
difundir teoría feminista que aplicada
también a nuestra realidad sociocultural
y política considerando qué
asegurando que en general escasea el
acceso a este tipo de información y
nosotros tenemos en común que dentro de
nuestras formaciones
trabajamos desde las artes y desde las
artes escénicas desde el diseño de
diseño textil pero también la historia
las ciencias sociales la literatura la
vinculación con el territorio y también
otras otras expresiones artísticas que
hemos yo incorporando de manera
autoridad así como en la música por
ejemplo y la búsqueda sonora que
nosotros tenemos de nuestro trabajo
entonces con esa con ese objetivo esa
premisa de difusión de esta idea de que
constituimos el colectivo y para
nosotras el feminismo no es solamente no
se queda solamente en lo temático no se
queda solamente la idea en el que se
dice sino en el cómo se dice ustedes
están sorprendidas por la acogida de su
activismo esto fue una cosa que se
volvió completamente masiva
finalmente cuando un espacio de
negociación que nunca tuvimos y que
nunca tampoco pensamos en el ambiente
habla de los pocos espacios que hay para
mirar
y experimentar socialismo esto genera
una puerta finalmente así lo vemos como
son cuatro mujeres que decidimos hacer
algo con nuestra disconformidad social
transformamos lenguajes que no eran más
propicios y nos encanta
e
es importante lo que pasó es importante
porque nos da ese espacio para que el
juego nuestras ideas sean escuchadas y
considero que somos cuatro mujeres con
las ideas eso es súper importante para
el mundo actual que está ocurriendo con
grandes movilizaciones con grandes
sublevaciones sociales
un pensamiento más bueno ustedes
esperaban que esto se conociera tanto
normalmente el activismo el trabajo
social son actividades que se realizan
dentro del anonimato pero con ustedes
eso no pasó
yo nunca pensé de vida
[Música]
y especificó que responde mucho tiempo
que estamos viendo lo que le sostiene
general en la tecnología
pues hay que decirlo que conversar con
ustedes no es nada fácil fueron
muchísimos meses buscando contactar las
hasta que por fin logramos este tú a tú
y yo veo que en general no les gusta
mucho el micrófono son selectivas poco
hablan con los medios porque esa
precaución
[Música]
bueno son varias cosas en realidad
también parte importante es que hay una
desconfianza por parte de nuestra y
también por muchas partes de la sociedad
sociedad hacia los medios de
comunicación hegemónicos o masivos
que tienden a tergiversar cierta
información a cambiar los puntos de
vista de algunas cosas entonces también
nos ha pasado
nosotras sin estar acostumbrada a este
es a dar entrevistas o aparecer en la
televisión y mucho menos como quieres
algo que nunca esperamos vivir y que de
ninguna manera sabemos manejar entonces
no ha pasado una oportunidad es como de
que aparecer de que os preguntan cosas y
luego igual la televisión por ejemplo
termina dando vuelta a lo que dijimos
editamos partes súper importantes que
nosotras de tema estamos hablando
por ejemplo
los cartageneros de chilenos denunciaron
a nosotras por incitar a la violencia y
nosotras nunca recibimos una
notificación formal por parte de esa
denuncia y si nos enteramos a través de
latercera y cuando los medios que un
medio de prensa escrita entonces cuando
las abogadas que no están ayudando
pidieron esa denuncia se demoraron
muchas semanas en entregarle a ella que
son las que están ayudando esa
información y sin embargo la tercera
este medio de comunicación la tengo la
tenía desde mucho antes y no y nosotras
éramos las denunciadas en este caso no
tenemos acceso a esa información
entonces ahora hay por lo menos en el
tema y no se me guste pero hay una cosa
entre el poder el poder de la
información que manejan los medios de
comunicación una manipulación de esa
información y los poderes del estado y
que aquí son los que tienen el monóculo
de la violencia también hay mucha
criminalización de la protesta social
constantemente entonces
y eso nos lleva a nosotras a alejarnos
lo más posible de vernos expuesta a
estas situaciones hay que tergiversar lo
que estamos hablando y para nosotras
como viento decía lo importante que es
el trabajo lo importante es el feminismo
no nuestras vidas personales por ejemplo
que también tienden a preguntar
sólo interesa a nadie le interesa
pero la
lo importante de la idea está en el
trabajo y eso es lo que hay que hablar y
es muy importante que los medios lo
hagan bien porque ya era hora ya era
hora de que el feminismo tuviera una
importancia en los medios de
comunicación porque son quienes generan
gran parte de la opinión pública
respecto a los temas entonces está bien
que lo esté sigamos hablando de medios
de comunicación es ciertamente hay
responsabilidades de nosotros
periodistas que muy frecuentemente nos
quedamos cortos para informar con
enfoque de género a veces no hablamos en
el lenguaje de los derechos humanos y un
ejemplo son las víctimas de violencia
machista en qué estamos fallando
nosotras cuando estudiamos por ejemplo
la violación estudiamos analizamos lo
que como los medios de comunicación
hablaban de estos temas
y pone y revictimiza en otra una vez más
otra vez a quienes sufren de lesión o de
feminicidios pueden hacer un perfil de
la víctima por en fotos desde su de sus
redes sociales hacen un perfil
psicológico de las víctimas y sin
embargo de los victimarios no sabemos
nada apenas sus iniciales con suerte
entonces no queremos ser parte de eso no
queremos estar involucradas con gente
que que ayuda
a perpetuar la cultura de la violación
miren las tesis lograron abrazar a miles
por no decir millones de mujeres en todo
el mundo empezaron siendo ustedes cuatro
y ahora las voces se multiplican y se
multiplican esto nos muestra que que
tantas personas se adhieran a sus
palabras que nos dice
es una consecuencia directa y de muestra
de que el sistema patriarcal está en
todas partes si las opresiones de género
están en todas partes operando en las
distintas culturas nos pasan todas las
fronteras y eso es altamente preocupante
si bien por supuesto que es maravilloso
ver este ejercicio de reapropiación de
la performance y de también que para
nosotros lo que significa que ya está
ver formas deja de ser nuestra sino que
es de todas y todas quienes tanto
mujeres como personas de las disidencias
se re apropian de este material y luego
lo habitan lo movilizan accionan también
desde su propio territorio y desde
también las demandas relativas a su
propio territorio eso sin duda es
hermoso porque
de vela una red enésima nosotros siempre
de subterránea que nos une sí y que
traspasa absolutamente todo pero lo que
es terrible es que demuestra que la
problemática es transversal que el
global sí que la presión es constante
está sucediendo en todas las esferas de
nuestra vida más aún cuando vemos estas
articulaciones entre sistema patriarcal
el sistema capitalista neoliberal pero
como lo conversamos una vez con una
mujer activista de la india en un
conversatorio ella decía algo muy
certero que era así como el problema es
global la solución también ha de ser
global y esperamos vivir para ver ese
cambio y ver el patriarcado de
capitalista el capitalismo neoliberal
arder y caer al atenerse sea en más
justa libres de las opresiones el
marketing tanto aquí como allá comentó
son las tesis para france24 vivas nos
queremos sigan en france 24
[Música]